[Music]
today what are we doing isaac we are
going fishing
yes and it's your is it your first time
fishing ever or is it
it is yeah oh very cool so me and tiff
recently got
into fishing we just bought fishing rods
and our good friend
andrew he's been fishing a lot lately
i think it's one of those things where
like you're in quarantine
and there's not a whole lot to do and
you're just looking for things to do
and one of the things that he decided to
pick up was fishing and he dragged us
out to go fishing one time and we're
like man this is really really fun
and so now me and tiff got her own
fishing rods we even got isaac
one tiff is doing podcast stuff today so
she won't be joining us
but it will be a boy's night out
fishing and then andrew's joining us
what are you looking forward to the most
uh catching a fish catching the fish
eating it
and eating it that'd be really really
fun i've always been
really really interested in that kind of
lifestyle whether it be fishing or
hunting like hunting for your own food
and stuff
like that's something that's always
piqued my interest
it's kind of like this you know
survivalist kind of mentality and just
being able to you know handle yourself
if there weren't any stores and stuff
and just you know rely on nature that's
always been really really cool
oh and by the way the world looks like
it's ending
all right we're at the pier we got isaac
set up over here
you got your little weight you got your
little uh your rig over there what kind
of uh what kind of bait we're using
today
we're using squid squid have you had any
luck yet so far with uh
getting any bites no because um whenever
i cast it out
uh-huh oh really you're still trying to
practice yeah it takes a little getting
used to i think right here it's like
oh it got stuck on the that's the anchor
that's where you tie the string to it
and it just takes practice and it just
takes a lot of getting to know your
fishing rod
yeah oh there you go you just did it
nice you got ak over here how you doing
sir
nada nada nothing today nothing nothing
not one bite i know i think the fishes
are kind of like
it's too gloomy to go eating food today
is it ashy out here at all
it's not ashy it is it is right where i
live i can't i don't see it here
yeah it actually feels nice it feels
like the weather here is a lot better
too like you can
breathe a lot better because out where
we are it's like you can't breathe it's
like it feels like you're being
suffocated by the smoke and the ash and
stuff nice little break from all that
nothing's biting today by the way this
thing just fell off my fishing pole
and didn't know that this part of a
fishing pole could actually break off
and it's actually broke i can't screw it
back in or anything so
great so much for going cheap on buying
fishing poles
i'm starting to like fishing as a hobby
so thinking i'm going to
stop by like a real fishing store
and get a decent fishing pole
oh that was a good cast you're getting
pretty good you learned quick
[Music]
i think your fishing pole broke too
that's hilarious bring it in oh my
goodness
oh no no it didn't break it didn't break
oh no i did
i think it snapped off yeah look it it
snapped off
two fishing poles broke on the same trip
the luck we have honestly i think it's
we should just
probably have spent more on a decent
fishing pole yeah
that's so funny both our fishing poles
broke
i mean yours yours mainly broke mine is
still usable
yeah you're just missing the the one on
the end the tip
should have known it's made in china
hey what's up buddy
i don't got nothing for you give him a
whole squid
[Music]
there we go fishies don't want to come
out to eat at least
we get to feed someone else there you go
happy eating now he's just waiting for
us to throw more food
he does something best yeah he's like a
dog
it's a sea dog all right so after trying
to get our own
fishies we decided to pay for some
fishies and we're gonna eat some
seafood at the pier it's weird because
as i'm trying to fish
i'm always like getting hungry and like
one and eat fish
is that a thing like as you're fishing
you it's like do you do you normally get
hungry when you
fish and you want to eat fish so like i
always want to eat fish
i don't i don't always crave fish but
when i do i really really want it
and fishing brings that out of me for
some reason like i just
really have to like last time when we
went fishing we had we had the
the fish tacos it was a must-have what
about you
yeah yeah you actually craved seafood
today which is something that you never
crave for so at home isaac and tiff
rarely ever eat seafood and never crave
it i'm using this as an
end with you isaac i'm gonna get you to
like seafood and then we're gonna be
seafood buddies moving forward go fish
and then get some seafood
true and then sitting next to these guys
i'm like man
we should have ordered a fat ass main
lobster
these things are huge that one right
there the next to the main lobster looks
like a
giant grasshopper that one right here
delicious gigantic sea bugs look at that
clam soup that's why i utilize it that
looks so
good it smells like the ocean it does
this is exactly what i wanted i think
seafood is the one
food animal that when i look at it when
it's alive i'm already salivating
but i can't look at a chicken like that
and i can't look at a cow like that but
when i look at
lobsters crawling around or fish
swimming around i'm already salivating
how's the soup it's pretty good pretty
good
yeah oh i can smell your soup smells
really really good flavor of the sea
that is delicious
oh wow that's so good
hey yeah we did we didn't catch any fish
but now we uh we're eating at the beer
you know we're getting some seafood
because we're craving what we were
supposed to catch
even though we were going to catch and
release but we're just craving the
potential having
a dinner that we would have caught so
now we're living our fantasies by
paying for it at a restaurant
[Music]
me